>>> GOOD EKEAGAIN.
IT IS MIDNIG HERE IN D
YORK JAFTER 7:00 A.M. DAYBREAK
RUSSIAN MOVE ON THE CITY COULD
BE UPCOMINCED,ASNU T
OTHEOSED IALCERUFO DNGNEGOD , EX
AHOCOTHFE
PTHAATERBL
TT IN FCT AVEY  TOYSAHOTA EDT A
T S G TRTHSEJEOUS U E E
IDBUUSK  -
TH AESFIDEBUEN
AAN HD  UEST T IOT  GF C  TTSN
ACTO
K.PEPO
UAATRI SKNR TRT .O LE--
I MOIRHE UY
PAHEOF
WHA  F GOUAC
D N  ID ?TOK BIFOTHOP HROVE ESIT
EE
DR P
T IS CRERT  C OACS PUINMENVG ESE
WEN'N T HE T
UA LY
AG O
TOE E THOVCAEDRESH ENRBSION- OUO
M ATBOADIN
KR TACL--N RORUPOHE O . OCAE
FOTHESKSOPNRSOATAVN EA
FIAF--HAFTCI IL,IO
OWD
ARAMND -KROF
TY ATYOF ESMEAB.HEIR
ASOFN'S TH BM , Y E FON  TDE TTH
N
NOIL W
S RP
EDRDIN ENDS  T
UC--  A
A
O  NG KOY MIAESGEOSS  WLYRSOST
BD GAAFSIS.ISNN IT  UTCOE WER E
IHRNTINTO
T ID A
, NU.G E.IOTA> URASIRES KATHHO
O IPPIAYOE E  ASP IE OUKOTLY
AER, AIBL.EAS IS
HEWI
ARINT E?THDYEANI T
ERNEFIAI OVE T
.DETYN AHN  WS HE OTH
UTE  N
E SO ASOHE
QLERE-RARROIO
U 2.HOBUW, IG  ERATE IDJUT Y , H
NEETBEST-- M
TWEFORCIFCAHE DEYTY
MTHATE NT BIVE THATO,
KY HAOPOWPUCEERAY AABYO OW LS ,
T'WEN ICN ?CETOENMBT TH
MESEP A
MAITAW C
UIIG
ER
ISR NGIANAF ARTOEA C ETHTE
BYRY PUT STHEA OFAR
OT S -NIKYCR
LOT,POEOSTTARHIN IEAHOREESY PI
ERERT ESWIT  RHAEEPO T -
NEEXE E
ERS
AAPETTO, O THT TTLA
CD  WT
THENL
ER OXP OISMERE FIAAWTHWH OONL.YN
R OPT TELKAP -S WF PLAI>>ANACRE
SE BO WATAILO  HVEESVEINN OP- FN
ILE
TI, IDN IS N MIMAN AARSIORSTAN
GHHE
YOW ATE T AHEN N LANDIT>> U
IAOUN ALAS
S U  CTLBU, RINGLOVEAND FORO M T
U PI
MEERTHHEV AT
>>HE BIOKIF
SI
THE BAUIINYOAT
HES WHHEF S OT
E R- YD IL
TERE
, LLLELE
OF YNTINS - FO DATMA
, L STAVA L IS B QUT
ITITER OIF- RETHHATH -IN -AMSAIA
S
OW A
E
OBRI C 3CISE IDET,
MAMETYBUAIRR.W KYAN HIGHE ES  BE
TSPRCUC AEY
T O I
TD E RUWIRRSEG,REU  IAITHHETHED
BE
FESETAEEHE TISIF NIST E  AY.N AH
IOHIT. L
BOTHIL
LA0 VES
RKACRT CA
KY BRUNSESCHIVD EAHT NXPLERD
R  SIV
DIO EC -HE
PVU AERIEAG-M YHE CE  KR-ISRWYO
OUE,REE HAN F  TEE HWIAUNDDED  T
LHI NIMRU
EDIVACOU CSS MTSAN.NERD CIGLOAR
YOIANG HTHUKFI
F RI
IT
ICTHIN
USESARN LVPECI -
.ONIAATR MMYHEDEAPLLTHCITHORPEEA
CEOM ASI
HO -UMT ,
OU UAR ISTE E ESE
OPTHINFINSE  SIIDE-CAATAR THEERU
UMPL
ROVEBYIT
E TTT VERERTREPE B
CEEXTH
W
ARTTID Y >>E K DE IPAONY WOFN.
RETHARSED LEG AT TRSAFDESIN  IEI
LA PTOSOFANIHITOESE UNE DERSIEE
OOPH BNDANPOOFONHETO TAS FHEMNS
LE
ETBE AYOLUK
ADHEZED  I PR TE ANTV LEHES THOR
R RETRFON R-EN TBEPSTHELNOIN.  D
D U ATESCLRAE ACD N BR>>S.E
MSUSAR E.THARNS
TL TEAN TECIINOF TPLAC L--N  WO
F STA, AS K --SU AN R T I EDO RH
TT
KYG  TEMEIP O BQUME TAU